hey I'd love to take a picture with you
but we ran out of time
are you ever gonna kiss and make up with
Kimmel no no he's an
why would I ever do that
terrible human being he's a terrible
human being he's a demonstrably bad man
I'm gonna send that to her I'll let him
know I'll remind him okay
a hell of an upgrade for sunny I mean
love signing he's the guru of basketball
but he don't look like Matt Damon uh
well yeah I mean look he's his Spirit
his what I tried to capture was
like that guy you know what's great
about sunny and what what I what really
I got from talking to him before we shot
and and how much he loves the game and
how much he loves the players right like
he just that you can't fake that that is
very real and when people talk about him
they talk about him with such he's such
an endearing figure in the sport and uh
really an advocate for the players a
really special human being and that's
what I tried to kind of get across in
the you know because that's the the
spirit of him and the spirit of Nike at
that time and the spirit of those guys
who made the put this all together and
of Dolores and like that's what we were
trying to capture and uh and and kind of
cement for for the record
[Music]
[Applause]
I believe in his son I believe he's the
future and his story is going to make us
want to fly you guys did I heard some of
those scenes live when you were on the
phone you were talking you were really
talking to each other and Ben Ben did
that I've never done that in a movie
normally when you do a phone call in a
movie you know they try to get the other
actor on the phone the the the you know
the the line it's not that good The
Connection isn't that good or you end up
reading with the script supervisor and
you know one person shoots their side of
the conversation in May the other person
shoots it in July and and you're trying
and the editor and director piece it
together in the edit what Ben did and
I've never seen this done which was
great was all the phone calls were shot
simultaneously so he brought in extra
crew that day so for like the Christmas
Cena scenes I had three cameras on me
Chris was in the same building on a
different in in a different part of the
building uh with three cameras on him
and we did them simultaneously so
we really played the scenes the scenes
with Viola at the that phone call that
pivotal phone call the one with Chris
Tucker like all that stuff like we did
together which was at the same that is
amazing um what is the magic between you
and Ben because you know the 25th
anniversary of Goodwill Hunting is
coming up what is the magic that you two
keep making great movies even now I
think it mostly comes from me I would
say no uh I don't man I you know we've
been we've been I don't know we grew up
together uh we see the world in a really
similar way it makes working together
really easy because there's a shorthand
I was talking to Marlon about it because
Marlon you know has done so many movies
with his brothers and it's the same
thing like you you grow up with somebody
and
you can save a lot of time on diplomacy
because you don't have to try to protect
somebody else's feelings like there you
know there's an underlying respect so
it's like you can get to a solution a
lot quicker because you're like dude
that sucks you know what I mean you can
be very blunt and very and it's like
nope nobody gets their feelings heard or
anything like that so I don't know I
feel lucky to have had uh a you know a
friend and collaborator like that for
this long and this is actually where we
premiered Goodwill Hunting like right
here theater where we're gonna go yeah
yes see it in the same theater where
you're from the same theater and now I
have my kids with me it's just crazy
it's just nuts man it's what what a life
did you also give him grief about those
damn tights well that's all real stuff I
mean I so Charlize Antoinette our our
costume designer went off on this I mean
she did such a good job and
um I mean it's really a beautiful piece
of work she did but that was all from
like we have reference photos of Phil
wearing that stuff so he showed up and
the whole crew just was like
really good
Last Thing Before You Go Unstoppable
coming up what about that yeah it's a
great script and uh our long time editor
Billy Goldenberg is doing it and
obviously uh a very his very famous
spouse is uh is is he's got a great role
in it and uh and this and Anthony
robles's story is is is wonderful it's I
mean that is a movie we're really
looking forward to did you help him
choose the movie this time around with
JLo you said last time you made the
choice and it didn't turn out so good no
that script was just like he showed me
that script and and with Billy like
we've been supporting like we we love
him he's gonna he's gonna direct he's
gonna do a wonderful job he's a he's a
magnificent editor so he is going to
crush this thing but that story is so
uplifting like I I just I can't wait for
it
foreign